o sol de 20 e os do estado fazer uma
lanterna usando duas garrafas de água ou
então de sumo do sul moções bonitas
potência várias curta em que os
elefantes gêmeos
sou mais tempo que tem que aguentar que
os gastos o que é isto que vou fazer
obviamente eu comprar um quilo e no que
eu comprei um léo tenha luz branca então
vou ter que usar essa aqui cima ea bola
e teria sido muito boa para usar o aluno
só que é resgatada ia mas se vocês não
tiverem um kit comprar e que convém
vocês verem a caixa nem para ver as
luzes que os levam dados podem ter algum
brinquedo velho que você estava lá em
casa uma coisa para estragar desde que
não seja a nossa televisão oz foi grife
cco é tão má calabar que eu gosto no
início da rodada pelo grupo ligado à pré
estão agora em portugal passou assim com
esta luz aqui na casa
sinto muito bem aqui e ali khan fica tem
graça lá a criança vai regular o santa
está tudo mais
só não sei se era uma bomba o telhado
então vamos lá só comecem por ter esta
parte cônica e com cuidado em direito em
tudo mas não sou já e também fica mais
bonita como a senhora frontal cor parda
rosca e velha e arte nas barbas para não
atrapalhar no passo seguinte
apesar de várias províncias do picolé
não sei quantos centímetros de
comprimento e está em más vamos desejar
seguir vou deixar na descrição do vídeo
porque é muito importante que vocês usem
a mesma medida que eu vou usar cair seja
sua voz foi melhor sair vocês cortam na
mesma ilha e foi mais pequeninos é vocês
têm que encontrar alguma coisa para ser
ouvido o substituto
hoje acusa agora cola só na extremidade
deste projecto e cuba assim no fundo ou
por outro vai ficar 90 graus com o
primeiro e mais um que também vai ficar
90 graus com o primeiro mas vai ficar no
lado oposto do último criou colocar é
assim um banco pequeno seja você tem que
ter um pouquinho sim vem pedindo que
caiba lá dentro e não atrapalha depois
na parte de puxar de cursos tanto com
política seja vejam que aberto vai
conseguir fazer a parte elétrica e
depois vou cobrir
então vocês tenham cuidado para que os
políticos vocês colocarem ler os dois
sejam clientes e explodem servem para
impedir que as pilhas saiu pela parte
econômica
imaginem que eu fiz assim uma espécie de
mola aproveitando uma das garrafas e vou
usar fio a volta mas vou dar várias
voltas para aumentar a superfície de
contato cair isso quanto mais vocês
quiserem lá é melhor assim vai evitar
que haja aquelas falhas de luz
vejam que pisa fica lá travada e fica
também em contato com o fio fazer um
furo no meio de uma das tampas e vou
usar um pequeno da steel azin mais
grosso
vejo aqui parece um pião e orando sem
contar com as pilhas e tem que ficar
encostado à superfície de tampa fora
daqui 890 grau
vocês têm que estar o resto vai ficar
tudo encostado na tampa e usei bastante
colo
agora vou pôr o outro filme que vai ver
o que o faz uma espécie de argola dobras
integral
o espaço fio por dentro
mesmo que como é que isto vai funcionar
o filme mais grosso vai passar pelo meio
da argola e vai contactar numa das
pilhas e quando você riscarem vai
acontecer e que os filhos vão ficar
apertadas entre aquela conexão que o
ficha limpa e com a parte da garrafa e
que o fio grosso a cair e no fio grosso
contato é que a lagoa ou seja vai ficar
num circuito fechado
agora vou usar uma tampa assim eu acho
que era do leito maior e vou usar para
suporte para o meu lado eu tenho dois
leds e vou fazer o primário comum e é
quase toda a gente tem esse lado aqui
mas se vocês tiverem daquilo cuidado
eu nunca tinha visto vem no kit e fiquei
bastante está muito gosto
e vejo aqui e agora vou puro qual o
hamas tenha cuidado para não tapar com a
partida a lusa caiu no colo só na parte
de trás do ego
diante de vocês conectaram leva os
filhos convenceu é docente porque é
importante que o - de novo - demais no
mais é não tiver aí vocês têm terá tudo
e voltar a pôr os filhos mas na
popularidade inversa e essas pernas tão
cadeirante então dobra maneira queira
não atrapalha quando forem colocar ela
pra dentro
eu gosto nesta parte desse projeto e que
vocês não se deve usar o ferro de solda
projetos que num caso do ferro de solda
e veja que deixou vincado grande para
conseguir fazer isto seja puxou o fio ea
justa é aquela base com led
tudo bem pra fora
por lá cole mas nos três níveis de cola
em três vezes mais forte do que o outro
eu fiz o resultado final cinco internas
tudo por dentro e depois por fora e
mesmo assim foi uma sugestão de algum
projeto só deixar os comentários que vai
expor tento fazer é esse trabalho de
tchau